yeah hello welcome to this life's
livestream announcement is a second
announcement today but this is for an
event that's going to be played on
sunday sunday 20 seconds so it makes it
tomorrow from the day it is posted yeah
I've been playing a blitz match against
Grandmaster nuke LaLoosh made also from
Germany is currently in the US for four
studies but yeah we'll play on Sunday
and this will be a match of of blitz
games four minutes plus two second
increment it will be and it will be how
would you call that yeah raise to 5 I
guess would be the right expression in
English so first to get 5 points wins
the match so we would be yeah the best
that we could get would be nine games
but you never know maybe one of us
winsome grins early I played them
Nicholas perform in a two-game match
which are one but two games it's not a
real match so yeah I'm looking forward
to that this will be streamed on my own
my own shadow just explained without the
gap um it will also be streamed by
Nicholas um I'm not quite sure I think
he probably would stream on YouTube but
I'm not one hundred percent sure if you
are a member of chess 24 you can also
see the links on chest 24 side um he
would definitely analysis in the used
tube in his on his youtube channel so i
probably think he will stream on youtube
yeah okay make sure to join me will be
fun on Sunday what are the times it will
be a six in the evening Central Europe
in time makes it noon on the US east
coast so yeah hoping for many of us and
participants in the twitch chat okay
thanks guys